the growing Global concern about the
possible spread of new covet variants
amid the worsening Health crisis in
China the outbreak is overwhelming
hospitals in many parts of the country
after the government suddenly dropped
its zero covet policy last month more
countries around the world are now
joining the U.S in imposing new rules on
travel from China Elizabeth Palmer has
more on China's covet battle
covet infections may be surging in China
but the young the fit and the healthy
have lost no time reclaiming their
freedom and the pleasures of normal life
it's quite another story in the
country's crowded hospitals where
medical staff are working flat out to
treat covid patients many of them
elderly
in his new year address China's
president Xi Jinping didn't mention the
protests that erupted in November
demanding an end to restrictions or the
fact that just Days Later his government
abruptly lifted its zero covid policy
sending the virus ripping through the
population it's still too early to know
if or how much she's handling of the
pandemic has damaged him or the
Communist party but in his speech he
called for Unity and warned of tough
challenges ahead exactly how tough isn't
clear social media posts have shown
overflowing mortuaries and Rural
hospitals like this one in such one lack
both adequate Heating and drugs but
China isn't publishing reliable data on
either coveted cases or deaths I think
the most we can say is that it's really
bad one worry globally had been a new
lethal variant could emerge from China
and restart the pandemic well the virus
is evolving all the time the information
that we do have doesn't suggest that
there is any new variants coming out of
China that is good news but the current
variant is still plenty dangerous and it
looks poised for a second wave as
millions of City dwellers travel home to
the countryside for Chinese New Year
taking the virus with them for CBS
mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Tokyo